From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Tobin Low, sitting in for Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目。我是托宾·洛，代班伊拉·格拉斯。
There's a story in my family that I love. It's actually a story about love, and it's one that I both fully enjoy, and is also the source of many years of romantic frustration. It starts with my mom as a teenager growing up in San Francisco Chinatown. A woman at the church she went to comes up to her one day, and says--
我家里有个我特别喜欢的故事。它其实是一个关于爱的故事，我既完全享受它，它同时也是我多年来在感情上感到沮丧的源头。故事要从我妈妈十几岁时在旧金山唐人街长大说起。有一天，她在教会遇到一位女士，对方走到她跟前说——
I have a nephew who's just perfect for you. And I'm going to set up this date, and you're just made for each other. You have to meet each other. And she was determined to make that happen.
我有个侄子非常适合你。我打算撮合你们俩约会，你们真是天造地设的一对。你们一定要见见面。她当时非常坚定地要促成这件事。
Maybe you can see where this is going. This is, in fact, my very own How I Met Your Father story. Anyway, my parents were both invited to a party where they could see each other for the first time.
也许你能猜到接下来会发生什么。这实际上就是我自己的“我是如何遇到你父亲”的故事。总之，我父母都被邀请参加了一个聚会，他们就在那里第一次见到了对方。
So there's a room full of people, and I don't know which one he's going to be. And so I'm sort of scanning the room, and I look at some people and think, oh, well, maybe that one has a really good personality.
当时满屋子都是人，我不知道他会是哪一个。所以我一直在扫描全场，看着有些人心想，哦，好吧，也许那个人性格特别好。
So you're saying there were some real uggos in the room.
所以你是说屋里确实有一些长相不敢恭维的人。
Well, they were just-- you know, they probably have a great personality.
嗯，他们只是……你知道，他们可能有个很好的性格。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
And so when I finally got introduced to him, I just was so relieved that he was good-looking. He met my expectation of what I hoped it would be. It was like, this huge sigh of relief.
所以当我最终被介绍给他时，我真是松了一口气，因为他长得很好看。他满足了我对他外貌的期待。那种感觉就像，长长地舒了一口气。
My dad was 19 at the time. My mom, 18. Their first date was at a French restaurant. She liked his good looks and that he was kind. He liked how quietly assured she was. Afterwards, they went to the movies, saw The Graduate, watched Dustin Hoffman bust Katherine Ross out of that wedding chapel, her bouquet still in hand. By the end of the date, they knew they had something special.
我爸爸当时19岁，我妈妈18岁。他们的第一次约会在一家法国餐厅。她喜欢他的长相和他的善良。他喜欢她那种沉静自信的样子。之后，他们去看了电影《毕业生》，看着达斯汀·霍夫曼把凯瑟琳·罗斯从那个婚礼教堂带走，她手里还拿着捧花。约会结束时，他们就知道自己遇到了一段特别的缘分。
But the part of the story that has stuck with me is this moment my mom talks about, a couple of months after that. My mom and dad ended up at the same college. And they'd spend every night together, hanging out at each other's dorm rooms. One night he walked her to the elevator, and he kissed her.
但故事中那个一直萦绕在我心头的部分，是我妈妈提到的一件事，在约会后的几个月。我父母最终上了同一所大学。他们每天晚上都待在一起，在彼此的宿舍里消磨时光。一天晚上，他送她到电梯口，吻了她。
We were saying goodbye at the elevator and had a hug and kiss. It was like, something magic about that moment was like, this is going to work.
我们在电梯口道别，拥抱并亲吻。那瞬间仿佛有什么魔法，觉得这一切都会成的。
They were married within the year. And they just have one of those marriages. They've been happily together for 52 years. The part that gets me-- they both knew it was right.
他们在一年内就结婚了。他们拥有那种令人羡慕的婚姻。他们幸福地在一起生活了52年。最打动我的是，他们俩当时都知道那是对的人。
As I grew up into an adult who dates, my dad was the one who said, don't worry, you'll figure it out. But my mom, on the other hand, she had more specific advice. Whenever I called about how a boyfriend and I had broken up or that dating was hard, her advice-- if you're with the right person, it should just feel like magic. If you don't feel magic, then it's time to bail.
当我长大成人并开始约会时，我爸爸总是说，别担心，你会想通的。但我妈妈，她有更具体的建议。每当我打电话告诉她我和男朋友分手了，或者约会很难时，她的建议是：如果你和对的人在一起，那应该感觉像魔法一样。如果你没感觉到魔法，那就是时候退出了。
Can you tell me what you meant by magic, as best as you can describe it?
你能尽可能地描述一下你所说的魔法是什么意思吗？
You look at the person and you feel that, against all odds, you're always going to-- that's the one for you. And there's no way of defining what that will be, I think, until it happens. And if it never happens, then I'm just not sure that's the relationship, at least, that I would want for you.
你看着那个人，你会感觉，尽管困难重重，你总是会——那就是你的命中注定。我认为在它发生之前，没有办法定义那会是什么。如果它永远没发生，那我不太确定那会是我想要为你选择的关系。
So the bar for magic is high.
所以魔法的门槛很高。
Yes. The bar for magic is very high.
是的。魔法的门槛非常高。
I wanted what my parents had, so I followed the advice. I'd go on dates-- dates that were perfectly fine, mind you. The conversation would be easy. The company, enjoyable. But at the end, I'd think, nope, didn't feel it. No magic.
我想拥有父母那样的爱情，所以我照做了。我会去约会——请注意，那些约会都还不错。谈话很轻松，相处也愉快。但在最后，我会想，不对，我没感觉到。没有魔法。
Or I'd convince myself that I did feel the magic, and then think everything, even warning signs, were proof of that magic. Case in point-- for my 25th birthday, an ex-boyfriend of mine gave me a card. Inside was a couple of "buy 10, get one free" coupons he'd filled up from his work lunches. He was giving me his freebies. And I wish I was lying when I say that my response was, wow, he ate 10 Hale and Hearty soups, for me? Magic.
或者我会说服自己确实感觉到了魔法，然后认为一切，甚至是危险信号，都是那种魔法的证明。举个例子——我25岁生日时，我的一位前男友送了我一张卡片。里面是他从公司午餐攒下的几张“买十送一”的优惠券。他把他的赠品给了我。我真希望我在说谎，但当时我的反应是，哇，他为了我吃了10份健康汤？这是魔法。
This is how most of my dating life as a 20-something went. But if my mom was on one shoulder telling me to look for magic, on the other shoulder was Elizabeth, one of my best friends.
我20多岁时的约会生活大抵如此。但如果我妈妈在肩膀的一边告诉我寻找魔法，那么在另一边，就是我最好的朋友之一伊丽莎白。
When it came to dating, she adopted a very different attitude. Her thought was, you have to be practical. It's not about searching for a big feeling. It's more about data collection. Elizabeth was sometimes going out on three first-dates a week from OkCupid. It got to a point where, when we'd talk about the guy she had dates with, it was easier to nickname them as "OK," like I met them on OkCupid, plus adjective.
在约会这件事上，她采取了完全不同的态度。她的想法是，你必须实际一点。这不是为了寻找某种巨大的感觉。这更像是收集数据。伊丽莎白有时一周会通过OkCupid进行三次初次约会。后来到了一个地步，当我们聊起她约会的对象时，直接给他们起绰号会更简单，比如“OK”加形容词，因为是在OkCupid上认识的。
So it was like, OKStandUp, because I think I went on a date with a standup, or like an aspiring standup. OKMedStudent. OKOccupyWallStreet. I don't know if you remember him.
所以比如叫“OK单口喜剧演员”，因为我觉得我曾和一个做单口喜剧的人约会过，或者像是个想做单口喜剧的人。或者“OK医学生”、“OK占领华尔街”。我不知道你还记不记得他。
Oh my god, right. I remember that guy.
噢天哪，没错。我记得那个人。
I do remember that guy. He kept pulling out his phone during their date to tweet about the movement.
我确实记得他。他在约会时不断掏出手机发推特报道那场运动。
Let's see how many retweets we get for this, I remember him saying on our second date. And I was like, this isn't going to have a third. This is very strange.
“看看这条能有多少转发，”我记得他在我们第二次约会时这么说。当时我就想，不会有第三次约会了。这太奇怪了。
Elizabeth's advice for me went something like this. Dating is like being an anthropologist. You go on a bunch of dates. You notice the bits and pieces that maybe you liked from each guy, slowly sharpening the picture of what type of person you might have a successful relationship with. For her, going on a lot of bad dates was just part of the process.
伊丽莎白给我的建议大致是这样的：约会就像做人类学家。你去参加一堆约会。你会注意到每个男人身上你可能喜欢的点滴，慢慢勾勒出什么样的人可能和你建立成功的关系。对她来说，参加很多糟糕的约会只是过程的一部分。
You're saying it's a numbers game.
你是说这是个概率游戏。
I'm saying it's a numbers game. I'm saying you have to, like-- you can't be disheartened by the fact that your numbers are going to look bad. You have to feel like, what have I got to lose.
我是说这是个概率游戏。我是说你必须，就像——你不能因为你的数据看起来很糟糕而气馁。你得觉得，我有什么好损失的呢？
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
A little bit less precious about every interaction.
对每一次互动没那么看重。
And her practicality-- it worked. Elizabeth eventually did meet someone. All that dating she did-- she says it allowed her to pay attention to all the small things she liked about him. They got married a couple of years ago. I officiated the wedding.
她的务实奏效了。伊丽莎白最终确实遇到了一位。她所有的那些约会经历——她说这让她能够注意到他身上所有她喜欢的小细节。他们几年前结婚了。我是婚礼的证婚人。
So why am I telling you all this? Because I feel like for anyone who has ever been single and wanted to find love-- and I'm talking about people that want lifelong partnership-- you have received advice from at least one of these two frustratingly opposed camps.
所以我为什么要告诉你这些？因为我觉得，对于任何曾经单身并渴望寻找爱情的人——我是指那些想要终身伴侣的人——你肯定从这两个截然对立的阵营中至少听过一个建议。
Camp one, the "look for magic" people, like my mom, and camp two, people like Elizabeth, who say it's more like math. Math is inexact, but I think you get my drift. They say use your head, not your heart. Be practical. Two warring factions, both with their champions, and a bunch of us in the middle, just trying to figure out which way is up. Who has it right? Will love find a way? Stay with us.
第一阵营是像我妈妈那样的“寻找魔法”派；第二阵营是像伊丽莎白那样说这更像数学的人。数学是不精确的，但我相信你明白我的意思。他们说用大脑，而不是用心。要务实。两个交战的阵营，都有各自的拥护者，而我们中间的一群人，只是在试图弄清楚该往哪走。谁是对的？爱情会有出路吗？请留下。
Act One, "10 Things I Require About You." So we're going to start off the show today with someone who is very much in the math camp, and who finds herself challenged by someone who could not disagree more. The math person-- her name is Zarna Garg. Her story starts when she was in her 20s. She was single, living in Cleveland, and the fact that she was single totally bothered her. This was in the late '90s, by the way.
第一幕，“关于你的十个要求”。今天我们节目要从一个非常有“数学派”倾向的人开始，她发现自己受到了一个完全持反对意见的人的挑战。这个“数学派”女孩叫扎尔娜·加格。她的故事始于她20多岁的时候。她单身，住在克利夫兰，而她单身的事实让她非常苦恼。顺便说一下，这还是90年代末。
You know, those years were the peak years of the TV show, Friends. Do you remember that show?
你知道，那些年是美剧《老友记》的巅峰期。你还记得那部剧吗？
Of course.
当然。
That show was the scariest show to me.
那部剧对我来说是最恐怖的。
Wait, why?
等等，为什么？
Because no one was ever getting married. They were dating, they were not dating, they were dating, they were on a break, they were off the break, then they were dating other people within the same friend group. Like, to somebody like me, who came from the world that I came from, that was a horror show.
因为从来没人结婚。他们约会，又不约会，约会，他们“休息”一下，又不休息了，然后又在同一个朋友圈里和别人约会。像我这种来自我那个世界的人来说，那简直是场噩梦。
Zarna moved to the US on her own when she was 16, leaving behind her family in India and a likely arranged marriage. She wanted to be independent and to go to college. She got into law school in Cleveland, so she was very much on track.
扎尔娜16岁时独自来到美国，撇下了在印度的家人和一段很可能发生的包办婚姻。她想独立并上大学。她考上了克利夫兰的法学院，所以她的人生规划非常清晰。
But at the same time, she still had this idea in her head that marriage provided a solidness. It was something she wanted deeply. So she found an online dating site for Indian singles, and decided to post an ad for herself. Posting an ad to find a husband-- not so unique in the world Zarna's from. But what was unique was the fact that she was posting for herself.
但同时，她脑子里仍然认为婚姻提供了一种稳固性。那是她深切渴望的东西。所以她找到了一个印度单身人士的在线约会网站，决定为自己发一则征婚广告。发广告找丈夫——在扎尔娜来自的世界并不稀奇。但独特之处在于，她是亲自为自己征婚。
The other ads were from aunts or moms trying to arrange matches for their daughters and nieces. Not Zarna. She was taking the reins. And her ad was, to put it lightly, specific. What she wrote was not a singles ad, so much as a list of qualifications. It was like a series of bullet points. She remembers it like this.
其他的广告都是姑姑或妈妈们试图为女儿或侄女安排婚事。但扎尔娜不是。她自己掌控大局。而她的广告，委婉地说，非常具体。她写的与其说是一个征友广告，不如说是一份资格清单。就像一系列要点说明。她记得当时是这样写的：
You have to be very serious. You have to have proof of your seriousness. I want to see what you do. I even would like to see some tax returns, and you know, what job prospects you have. I mean, it was nuts;
你必须非常严肃。你得有证据证明你的严肃。我想看你的工作。我甚至想看你的纳税申报单，以及你有什么职业前景。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。
She also said, you have to be brilliant. That was a big one because--
她还说，你必须很聪明。这一点非常重要，因为——
I figured, if I met somebody brilliant, life would be fine. And whatever problems would happen, we would work them out together, because he would be brilliant enough to figure that out.
我想，如果我遇到一个极其聪明的人，生活就会很好。无论发生什么问题，我们都会一起解决，因为他足够聪明去处理那些问题。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
So brilliant, like booksmart?
所以聪明是指那种书本上的智慧吗？
Oh, so I was very specific about that. I was like, I need to see proof of your brilliance.
哦，我对此非常具体。我说，我需要看到你聪明的证据。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
You know, I need to see where you went to college or whatever you're doing with your life. Oh, and also, I was like, you must have a good mother, because I don't have a mother, and this is my one chance to fix that.
你知道，我需要看你上了哪所大学，或者你这辈子在做什么。哦，还有，我说过，你必须有个好母亲，因为我没有母亲，这是我修复这一点的唯一机会。
She also figured they should have accurate data about her. She said, I'm a student, I'm short, only 5 feet tall. I'm not the skinniest person.
她还认为他们应该有关于她的准确数据。她说，我是学生，我个子矮，只有5英尺高。我不是那种最苗条的人。
I do think that my ad, as obnoxious as it was, had an element of honesty to it. An Indian ad would have been, fair and lovely, peaches-and-cream complexion, tall, skinny. I never used any of those words, because none of those words would have been true for me.
我确实认为我的广告虽然令人讨厌，但有一种诚实。一般的印度广告会写：皮肤白皙可爱、像桃子奶油般的肤色、高挑、苗条。我从没用过那些词，因为那些词对我来说都不真实。
You know, there might be somebody who hears your story and thinks, wow, that is kind of a ruthlessly practical way to go about finding a partner and finding love.
你知道，可能会有人听到你的故事后心想，哇，这确实是一种极其务实的寻找伴侣和爱情的方式。
But they're right. They're right. It is a ruthlessly practical way, and it should be, because marriage is a contract. And like all contracts, you should think twice before getting into it. I don't believe that just falling blindly in love is the answer.
但他们是对的。他们是对的。这确实是一种极其务实的方式，理应如此，因为婚姻是一份契约。像所有契约一样，你在签署之前应该三思而后行。我不相信盲目地坠入爱河就是答案。
Apparently, there were a lot of people who felt they met the criteria. Her inbox became flooded with messages, all from men who wanted to meet in person. Zarna picked a few of them, said sure, let's meet, but you have to come to Cleveland. And a surprising number said yes.
显然，有很多人觉得他们符合这些标准。她的收件箱被信息淹没了，全都是想要亲自见面的男人们。扎尔娜选了几个，说好吧，见个面吧，但你得来克利夫兰。出人意料的是，很多人都答应了。
Men flew from all over different parts of America to come meet me in Cleveland. And I was actually pretty clinical about it, and as were they, mostly, once they realized what the vibe was. We met at a McDonald's in Cleveland that had, like, open windows. So it felt safe.
男人们从美国各地飞来克利夫兰见我。我当时非常客观冷静，他们也基本如此，一旦他们意识到这是什么氛围的话。我们在克利夫兰的一家麦当劳见面，窗户是开着的，所以感觉很安全。
And they were all highly educated doctors, lawyers, entrepreneurs. And for one reason or another, it wasn't working out. They liked me, I didn't like them, or whatever. Or I liked them, they didn't like me.
他们都是受过高等教育的医生、律师、企业家。由于各种原因，没成。他们喜欢我，我不喜欢他们，诸如此类。或者我喜欢他们，他们不喜欢我。
What did she care? She had an inbox of hundreds of messages from other suitors who are just as qualified for the position of husband. What's that saying? I think it comes from Shakespeare, or maybe The Canterbury Tales. Thank you. Next.
她会在乎吗？她收件箱里有几百条其他苏格兰人的信息，他们同样有资格担任丈夫一职。那句话怎么说来着？我想它来自莎士比亚，或者是《坎特伯雷故事集》。谢谢，下一个。
It's in the middle of all these messages that she gets a different kind of message. And this person does not offer up his credentials or his tax returns. He simply writes--
就在这些信息中，她收到了一条不同寻常的信息。而这个人并没有提供他的资历或纳税申报单。他只是写道——
This isn't a real ad. Is it? Are you a real person?
这不是真的广告吧？是真的吗？你是真人吗？
The message goes on to make fun of her. It feels like a troll. And if this were a movie, the camera would zoom out of Zarna's window at her house in Cleveland. Maybe we would see a crude animation of a globe rotating on its axis. A dotted line moving from the US, going first to Europe, then zeroing in on Switzerland-- until the camera would zoom in on an office building in Zurich.
信息接下来嘲笑她。感觉像是个网络喷子。如果这是部电影，镜头会从扎尔娜在克利夫兰家中的窗户拉开。也许我们会看到一个粗糙的地球仪在轴上旋转的动画。一条虚线从美国出发，先到欧洲，然后聚焦于瑞士——直到镜头缩放到苏黎世的一栋办公楼。
Because that's where the message came from-- a computer programmer working late one night at his office. His job was fixing a Y2K bug for his company. I know. So '90s. His name was Shalabh. He was single. And when he found Zarna's ad while randomly surfing the internet, he thought it was ridiculous. He called over his colleagues, and said, hey, get a load of this girl.
因为信息就是从那里来的——一个深更半夜在办公室工作的电脑程序员。他的工作是为公司修复千年虫漏洞。我知道，太90年代了。他叫沙拉布。他是单身。当他偶然在网上浏览时发现了扎尔娜的广告，他觉得这简直太离谱了。他把同事叫过来，说，嘿，来看看这个女孩。
I mean, it was three of us that looked at it, because I called my friends in, and we were just making fun of it. We were like, I don't know who this girl is.
我是说，我们有三个人看了，因为我叫了我的朋友们，我们只是在拿它开玩笑。我们当时想，我不知道这女孩是谁。
What were the elements of it that you were making fun of in the ad?
你在广告中拿哪些要素开玩笑呢？
I mean, the seriousness-- a girl who is this much work even before she has met someone, can you imagine what she would be like into a serious relationship? It's like, start to finish, work, work, work, and no fun.
我是说，那种严肃劲儿——一个女孩甚至在还没见到人之前就这么较真，你能想象她在一段认真的关系中会是什么样吗？感觉就像从头到尾就是工作、工作、工作，一点乐趣都没有。
Cut back to Cleveland, small house in the suburbs. Zarna types back, "Yeah, I'm real." He replies--
转回克利夫兰，郊区的一栋小房子。扎尔娜回复道：“是的，我是真人。”他回答说——
You know, what makes you think that you'll find someone? I doubt anybody would take on that amount of seriousness at such a young age, because there's almost no fun in your classified.
你知道，是什么让你觉得你能找到人？我怀疑没人会在这么年轻的时候就接受那种程度的严肃，因为你的分类广告里几乎没有任何乐趣。
I was like, yeah, and I'm actually on a mission to do something. What are you guys doing?
我说，是的，而且我实际上肩负着某种使命。你们在干什么？
She was like, I don't know who is the bigger loser--
她说，我不知道谁是更大的失败者——
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
--someone who is seriously seeking out a life partner, like myself, or someone who is just sitting in a random room, programming and surfing young women on the internet.
——是像我这样认真寻找人生伴侣的人，还是像你们这样随便坐在一个房间里，编程并上网搜寻年轻女性的人。
He's like, so have you gotten any responses? I was like, as a matter of fact, many, many responses. You want to see some? And I forwarded him a whole bunch of ads, responses that I had.
他说，那你收到回复了吗？我说，事实上，收到很多很多回复。你想看看吗？于是我转发了一大堆广告，就是我收到的那些回复。
And he was like, I can't believe this. And I said, why are you wasting my time? I was then getting irritated, because my ad clearly said, only contact me if you want to get married.
他说，我简直不敢相信。我说，你为什么要浪费我的时间？当时我已经很不耐烦了，因为我的广告明确说了，只有你想结婚才联系我。
Shalabh was not interested in getting married. His life was filled with travel and friends and skiing. Also, he lived an ocean away. He was not the solution to Zarna's problem. But they kept emailing. It was mostly them giving each other a hard time. This went on for weeks.
沙拉布对结婚没兴趣。他的生活里充满了旅行、朋友和滑雪。而且他住在大洋彼岸。他不是解决扎尔娜问题的办法。但他们一直发邮件。主要是互相刁难。这种情况持续了几个星期。
Then, he would then be like, hey, did you end up meeting that guy-- you know, the one you forwarded me? And I would be like, yeah, I met him, but I don't think it's going to work, and whatever. So we became friends, even despite my every intention to not make friends.
然后，他会问，嘿，你最后见那个男的了吗——你知道，你转发给我的那个？我会说，是的，我见了，但我觉得成不了，诸如此类。所以即使我百般不想交朋友，我们还是成了朋友。
Oh, so he was a little bit keeping tabs on your progress, too, then.
噢，所以他也在跟踪你的进展啊。
He was. I don't know why he was so curious, but he was.
是的。我不知道他为什么这么好奇，但他确实如此。
Oh, Zarna, I think we all know why he was so curious.
哦，扎尔娜，我想我们都知道他为什么这么好奇。
After so much back-and-forth, Shalabh had this feeling like, at this point, I can't not meet this girl.
在来回交流了这么多次后，沙拉布有一种感觉：到了这个地步，我不能不见这个女孩。
Well, he said he really wanted to meet me. And I told him that I was moving to New York for my first job, and because I thought I would have a higher likelihood of meeting an Indian guy in New York than in Cleveland. And he was like, I really want to meet you. And I said, OK, I can meet you at the airport.
嗯，他说他真的很想见我。我告诉他我正要搬去纽约找第一份工作，因为我觉得在纽约遇到印度男人的概率比在克利夫兰高。他说，我真的想见你。我说，好吧，我可以在机场见你。
Zarna says this is when I'm landing in New York from Cleveland. Shalabh says he can get a flight that arrives around the same time. Zarna says, OK, but I'm only willing to say a quick hi at the airport. She did not want to waste time on friend dates.
扎尔娜说这是我从克利夫兰飞到纽约落地的时候。沙拉布说他可以订一张差不多时间到达的机票。扎尔娜说，行，但我只想在机场简单打个招呼。她不想在朋友式的约会上浪费时间。
Because, as I said, I was mission-driven. The minute I reached New York, I had-- 2 o'clock, I was meeting this guy. 4 o'clock, I was meeting that guy. So there wasn't going to be a lot of time. And why was I meeting this guy from Switzerland anyway? Because there was no real interest there in that way. And he said, fine, I'll come to New York and we'll meet at the airport. It's fine. He said, I just need to see that you're real.
因为正如我所说，我身负使命。我到纽约的那一刻，2点我有约，4点我也有约。所以没多少时间。况且我为什么要见这个从瑞士来的人呢？因为在那方面并没有真正的兴趣。他说，好吧，我来纽约，我们在机场见。没关系。他说，我只是需要确认你是真人。
They found each other at the airport. Zarna remembers thinking he was cute, but also, he immediately annoyed her.
他们在机场找到了对方。扎尔娜记得当时觉得他很可爱，但也立刻觉得他很烦人。
He informed me at the airport that he had nowhere to go while in America. So now I'm like, now, you're stuck with me? I don't have a place to take you I barely had a tiny apartment for myself. And he's like, but I don't know. I'm here with my toothbrush and my passport. I have nowhere to go.
他在机场告诉我，他在美国没地方去。所以我现在心想，现在你是赖上我了？我没地方带你去，我刚勉强有一个留给我自己的小公寓。他说，我不知道。我带着牙刷和护照就来了。我没地方去。
Zarna says, fine, you can stay with me. She had made arrangements to stay at her cousin's apartment. He could crash. And then, in the cab on the way there, something about the anticipation of meeting face to face and then finally, seeing each other, something happened.
扎尔娜说，好吧，你可以住我那儿。她已经安排住表姐的公寓了。他可以凑合。然后，在去那里的出租车上，关于面对面见面的期待，以及最终见到对方，发生了一些事情。
When we met, from that point on, all the way to the apartment we couldn't keep our hands off of each other. It was really passionate.
当我们见面时，从那一刻起，一直到公寓，我们都无法将手从对方身上移开。那真是充满了激情。
They kissed. There was a spark. But they also both agreed there was nowhere for a relationship to go. Zarna was not going to let him get in the way. She kept her scheduled dates for that day. There were two of them. She dropped Shalabh off at the apartment and said, stay here, do not move, I have a husband to go meet.
他们亲吻了。有火花。但他们也都同意，这段关系没什么进展空间。扎尔娜不会让他挡路。她保留了那天预定的约会。一共有两个。她把沙拉布留在公寓，说，待在这儿，不许动，我有“丈夫”要去见。
And just like her routine in Cleveland, she arranged for them to meet in public places. First, in the lobby of the building she was staying at, then on to a coffee shop. What she had not planned on was that Shalabh would not stay at home like he promised. Instead, he crashed both of her dates, would just conveniently show up in the lobby or at the coffee shop.
就像在克利夫兰的例行程序一样，她安排他们在公共场所见面。先是在她住的大楼大厅，然后是咖啡店。她没算到的是，沙拉布并没有像承诺的那样待在家里。相反，他搅乱了她两次约会，总是很方便地出现在大厅或咖啡店里。
He would just be like, hi, I'm Shalabh, with no explanation. That made it even more suspicious.
他会说，嗨，我是沙拉布，没有任何解释。这让事情变得更加可疑。
Oh, he introduced himself to your dates.
噢，他向你的约会对象自我介绍了。
Yeah. And my dates were like, is this your brother? I'm like, no. But it was hard to explain to them what exactly was the relationship. So I would be like, no, no, he's just a friend. He's visiting. But, clearly, it looked odd.
是的。我的约会对象问，这是你哥哥吗？我说，不。但很难向他们解释我们究竟是什么关系。所以我只能说，不不，他只是个朋友。他来探亲。但显然，这看起来很怪。
Was your intent, you think, to throw off the date a little bit?
你觉得他的意图是搅乱你的约会吗？
A little bit to throw off the date, but remember, I was early 20s. Even though I had not much to show for it, I was fairly arrogant myself. Because at least in my mind, I was one of the top colleges in India, I was doing a job in Zurich, making good money. So I was certainly not insecure. If anything, on the other side of it, in terms of being more arrogant.
有一点点搅乱的意思，但记住，我当时20出头。即使没什么成就，我自己也相当傲慢。因为至少在我看来，我来自印度顶尖大学之一，在苏黎世工作，薪水丰厚。所以我当然不自卑。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是在另一面，表现得更加傲慢。
I see. But there was an energy of, like, let me see who this guy is.
我明白。但有一种能量是，“让我看看这家伙是谁”。
Yeah, let me see who this guy is, and what is so special about a doctor guy.
对，让我看看这家伙是谁，医生男有什么特别之处。
Zarna could have been annoyed by all this. But she found, somehow, she wasn't.
扎尔娜本可以对这一切感到恼火。但她发现，不知何故，她并没有。
By then, I had a friendship enough with him that even when I was on a date I was thinking about him. Like, I wonder what he's doing. So my brain was already all over the place about what exactly are we doing here.
到那时，我已经和他建立了足够的友谊，以至于即使在约会时我也会想到他。比如，我想知道他在干什么。所以我脑子里已经在纠结我们到底在做什么。
Zarna ended up spending a couple of days with Shalabh. They walked around the city, talked about their lives, debated about politics and how they felt about America, shared how they both grew up in India, how they had both left home.
扎尔娜最终和沙拉布共度了几天。他们在城市里散步，谈论各自的生活，争论政治和对美国的看法，分享在印度长大的经历，以及他们是如何离开家乡的。
He had his own loneliness. He had his own really difficult journey. He is an ambitious guy. I think something about my ad and my world made him feel like, oh, my god, this sounds like my world. You know? And something about dealing with him made me feel like he's not so dissimilar from me and how I think.
他有他自己的孤独，也有他非常艰难的旅程。他是个有雄心的人。我觉得我的广告和我的世界让他觉得，噢天哪，这听起来像我的世界。你知道吗？处理他的方式让我觉得他和我没什么两样，包括思考方式。
They both remember a turning point in that first visit, which brings us to the classic part of stories like this-- when it starts to rain.
他们都记得第一次访问中的一个转折点，这把我们带到了这类故事的经典桥段——天开始下雨的时候。
Titanic had just come out. I remember we went for that movie in the rain. She used to love getting wet in light rain, but refused to carry an umbrella. You know how New York rain is, right? It was pouring rain.
《泰坦尼克号》刚上映。我记得我们冒雨去看了那场电影。她过去喜欢在小雨中淋湿，但拒绝带伞。你知道纽约的雨是怎样的吧？当时雨倾盆而下。
And we'd just finish a 3-and-1/2-hour-long movie, where Jack was dead and Rose was going to go on with her life. And I'm like, that was probably the moment. And I'm thinking to myself, that is how fickle life can be, and do I really want to not have this woman in my life? Probably, that would be the one moment when I thought that this might be the woman for me.
我们刚看完一部三个半小时长的电影，片中杰克死了，罗丝要继续她的生活。我在想，那可能就是那一刻。我对自己说，生活竟然如此无常，我真的想让这个女人不在我的生命里吗？可能，那就是我想到她或许是我的命中注定的时刻。
And then, of course as everything we do ends up in a fight, we fought about it, too. Because there was space on that raft. He could have been saved. So then we started fighting about that and whether she should have thrown the necklace into the water or not.
当然，正如我们所做的一切最终都会演变成争吵一样，我们也为此吵了一架。因为那块木板上明明有空间。他本来是可以获救的。所以我们就开始争论那个，还有她到底应不应该把项链扔进水里。
It sounds like you kind of even enjoyed disagreeing with him.
听起来你甚至还很享受和他产生分歧。
Oh, my god. To this day, my favorite thing to do is to fight with my husband.
噢天哪。时至今日，我最喜欢做的事就是和我丈夫争吵。
If you haven't caught on by now, I suppose that's a spoiler. Within a couple of months of that visit, Shalabh bought Zarna an emerald-green ring. They were married a little over a year after he sent her the message that made her so mad. They've been together now for 24 years.
如果你到现在还没领悟，我想那是剧透了。那次访问后的几个月里，沙拉布给扎尔娜买了一枚祖母绿戒指。在发送那条让她火冒三丈的信息一年多后，他们结婚了。他们现在已经在一起24年了。
If I can do anything, I want to go on a long walk and have a robust fight with him about everything-- about the politics, the movies-- yes, of course. Absolutely.
如果我能做任何事，我想去散步，和他为所有事情进行一场激烈的争吵——关于政治、电影——是的，当然。绝对。
Yeah. What is it about the fighting that you enjoy?
是的。争吵的什么让你觉得享受？
He's really brilliant. That's the one thing I got right.
他真的很聪明。那是唯一我选对了的事情。
Zarna admits that, yes, some magic snuck into her life. But she sees this whole story largely as a victory for math. She wrote down exactly what she wanted, and she got it. Shalabh actually does match a bunch of the things on the list. For example, he has a good mother, and Zarna really loves her.
扎尔娜承认，是的，确实有一些魔法溜进了她的生活。但她主要将整个故事视为“数学”的胜利。她写下了她想要的，并且得到了。沙拉布确实符合清单上的很多条目。例如，他有个好妈妈，扎尔娜真的很爱她。
Shalabh, though-- sees the story totally differently. He thinks the fact that they met through this bizarre set of circumstances, it's an argument for magic. Which is funny, I'm used to couples disagreeing about why they broke up-- who said what, and who's to blame. But I've never known a couple who disagrees about the thing that brought them together.
不过，沙拉布看待这个故事完全不同。他认为他们通过这一系列奇异的境遇相遇，这本身就是对魔法的证明。这很有趣，我习惯了情侣们为了分手原因吵架——谁说了什么，谁该负责。但我从没见过像他们这样为了让他们走到一起的事由而争论的夫妇。
And this disagreement over math versus magic, practicality versus romance-- it's continued into everything about their lives. Zarna still considers herself the pragmatic one in the family, Shalabh more of the dreamer. And now that they're parents, it means they're giving their kids competing advice.
而这种关于数学对阵魔法、务实对阵浪漫的争执，一直延续到了他们生活的方方面面。扎尔娜仍然认为自己是家里务实的那一个，沙拉布则是梦想家。现在他们成了父母，这意味着他们给孩子提供的是相互竞争的建议。
He will tell my kids, oh, you should go fall in love. No, don't fall in love. This is what has caused all the problems in the world-- everybody falling in love. So, yes, he is the romantic, and it's like, I can't stop it. And I have to work around it with my kids, and remind them that their dad is wrong, entirely wrong. And our life is proof that I'm right.
他会告诉我的孩子们，哦，你们应该去坠入爱河。不，别坠入爱河。这就是导致世界上所有问题的原因——每个人都坠入爱河。所以，是的，他是浪漫主义者，我没法阻止。我不得不和孩子们沟通，提醒他们爸爸是错的，完全错了。我们的生活就是我正确的证明。
Well, and I could also say our life is proof that my romanticism has provided me with a very great career, a great family, good health, kids that are healthy. So what's wrong with that?
好吧，我也可以说我们的生活证明了我的浪漫主义给了我一份伟大的事业、美满的家庭、健康的身体、健康的孩子。所以那有什么问题吗？
I mean, you see why he's a problem? What's wrong with that is actually, my deep thinking and planning is what made all of that happen. It's not your romantic thinking. Am I right, Tobin?
我的意思是，你明白他为什么是个问题了吗？其实真正有问题的是，我的深思熟虑和规划才让这一切发生。不是你的浪漫思想。我说得对吧，托宾？
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I mean--
我是说——
I don't think he can take sides like that.
我觉得他没法选边站。
I am scared to take sides here.
在这里选边站让我很害怕。
If Ira was here, he would agree with me.
如果伊拉在这里，他会同意我的。
I don't know that I can authoritatively say who has it right here. But watching them each dig in their heels on their own point of view, it seems like together they balance each other out. And I imagine they force each other to see the world a little differently. Or, if not, at least they can argue about it.
我不知道我能否权威地断定谁是对的。但看着他们各自坚持自己的观点，看起来他们在一起互补。我想他们强迫对方从不同的角度看世界。如果不行，至少他们能为了这个吵上一架。
Coming up-- a case for magic from the luckiest and maybe most unrelatable among us-- those jerks-- sorry, people-- who fell in love at first sight. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来——来自我们中间最幸运、或许也是最不可同日而语的人——那些混蛋——抱歉，是那些一见钟情的人——对“魔法”的证明。芝加哥公共广播电台将在节目继续时为你揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Tobin Low today's show, "Math or Magic," stories of people finding love by trusting some mystical force in the universe or just being practical about it. And as we were putting together this show, every time we talked about this theme, it riled up the staff. People had a lot of big feelings about it. Turns out, lots of people here were trying to figure out this very thing in their own lives, which brings us to Act Two, "Crazy Stupid Love."
这里是《美国生活》。我是托宾·洛，今天的节目是“数学还是魔法”，讲述人们通过信任宇宙中的某种神秘力量或仅仅是务实地看待问题而找到爱的故事。当我们在筹备这期节目时，每次聊到这个主题，都会引起工作人员的争执。大家对此感触良多。原来，这里很多人都在自己的生活中试图弄清楚这一点，这就引出了第二幕，“疯狂愚蠢的爱”。
So when you're talking about the magic camp of people, there's a group that emerges as maybe the most magic of magic. I'm talking about people who say that from the moment they saw their partner, they just knew, for sure, that this was their person. One of our producers here, Aviva DeKornfeld, is skeptical about these claims, and also a little envious. Here's Aviva.
所以，当你谈到“魔法”阵营的人时，出现了一群可能最有“魔法”色彩的人。我说的是那些从见到伴侣的第一眼起，就肯定知道这就是自己命中注定的人。我们节目的一位制作人阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德对这些说法持怀疑态度，但也有一点嫉妒。下面是阿维娃。
I put out a call to see how many people out there had really felt this thing I assumed was reserved for rom-coms. And let me tell you, there are a lot of you. I got over 700 responses. It seems like all day, every day, people are out there running into their soulmate-- in airports, on buses, at bars.
我发起了一个征集，看看有多少人真正感受过这种我以为只存在于浪漫喜剧里的东西。让我告诉你，你们的人数不少。我收到了超过700份回复。看起来每天、每时每刻，人们都在机场、公交车、酒吧里遇到他们的灵魂伴侣。
One person met their partner on the side of the road after they'd gotten a flat tire. Another couple met at band practice. This one woman I talked to met her husband in the middle of the woods. She accidentally wrote his phone number down wrong, and they still ended up together.
有个人在路边遇到爆胎后遇见了另一半。另一对是在乐队排练时认识的。我采访的一位女性在森林深处遇到了她的丈夫。她不小心记错了他的电话号码，但他们最终还是走到了一起。
Liz met her person in her friend Ingrid's kitchen. She was 17 at the time, and they were hanging out, chatting, when Ingrid's brother came downstairs with a guy Liz had never seen before.
利兹是在她朋友英格丽德的厨房里遇到她那个“真命天子”的。当时她17岁，他们正坐着聊天，英格丽德的哥哥带着一个利兹从未见过的男人走下了楼。
I turned around, and he looked at me, and I looked at him. And we just went, oh my god. Like, both of us simultaneously just looked at each other, and boom, that's it, I've met the one.
我转过身，他看着我，我看着他。我们同时说，噢天哪。我们俩就像同时看着对方，轰，就是这样，我遇到了那个对的人。
What?
什么？
Yeah. And there was just this awkward, awesome silence.
是的。当时有一种尴尬又奇妙的沉默。
Liz's mom was there when this all happened, talking to Ingrid's mom.
利兹的妈妈当时也在场，正在和英格丽德的妈妈谈话。
And my mum turned to Ingrid's mom, and just said, oh my god, did you feel that? And Kate, their mother, went, oh my god, yes. That's electricity right there. And, yeah, we just knew from that moment on, we're the ones for each other.
我妈转向英格丽德的妈妈，说，天哪，你感觉到了吗？凯特，她们的母亲说，天哪，是的。那绝对是电光火石。是的，从那一刻起，我们就知道，我们是彼此的唯一。
How did you know that?
你怎么知道的？
I don't know, it was just this feeling.
我不知道，就是那种感觉。
They started dating two weeks later.
两周后他们开始约会。
We're still together today, and it's, what, 30-something years later. [LAUGHS]
我们今天还在一起，那是，什么，30多年以后了。（笑声）
Oh, my gosh.
噢，天哪。
[LAUGHS] I know!
（笑声）我知道！
Stories like Liz's drive me insane, because I love them. I get so swept up by the romance. And yet, they couldn't be more foreign to me. It's the certainty that Liz describes. I don't understand it.
像利兹这样的故事让我抓狂，因为我喜欢它们。我被这种浪漫深深吸引。然而，它们对我来说再陌生不过了。利兹描述的那种笃定感，我不理解。
What did it physically feel like?
那种感觉在身体上是什么样子的？
You know, I can feel it as if it was happening right now. It's just like a tightness in the chest, and like an adrenaline rush, like you've just seen a really big spider or something.
你知道，我现在回忆起来就像刚刚发生一样。就像胸口一阵紧缩，像肾上腺素激增，就像你看到一只很大的蜘蛛之类的东西。
How do you know-- I don't know, you're 17. How do you know it wasn't just hormones?
你怎么知道——我不知道，你才17岁。你怎么知道那不是荷尔蒙作祟？
I didn't. I didn't. Look, it very well could have been. But at that time, it was so real. It was just like being smacked over the head with a hammer, and like, that's the one.
我不知道。我确实不知道。听着，那完全可能是荷尔蒙。但在那个时候，它是那么真实。感觉就像被锤子重击了一下头顶，然后就觉得，就是他了。
I've never felt anything like that, no matter how wonderful the person I'm dating is, or how infatuated I feel. I've never been able to shake that gut feeling telling me, this is not forever.
我从未感受过那样的东西，无论我的约会对象多么好，或者我感觉多么迷恋。我也从未能摆脱那种肠胃里的直觉告诉我的声音：这不是永远。
In fact, all of my relationships have ended in some way or another because of my lack of certainty. Everyone in my life is exhausted by my endless romantic dithering. Days after my last breakup, my dad made a point to tell me that if I thought I would find someone better than my ex, I was mistaken.
事实上，我所有的关系最终都因为我的这种不确定性而以这样或那样的方式结束了。我生活中的每个人都对我无穷无尽的浪漫犹豫感到厌倦。在我上次分手几天后，我父亲特意告诉我，如果我以为能找到比前任更好的，那我就错了。
These people who get that lightning strike moment, with the big boom and flash of recognition-- they really feel like God's favorites, the lucky ones, somehow insulated from all the doubt plaguing the rest of us. Part of me, maybe the jealous part, is skeptical of stories like these.
那些获得闪电般瞬间的人，带着那种认出的轰鸣声和闪光——他们真的感觉像是上帝的宠儿，那些幸运儿，不知怎么地就对困扰我们其余人的所有怀疑免疫了。我内心的一部分，也许是嫉妒的那部分，对这些故事持怀疑态度。
Like, how could you possibly know in two seconds? You don't know anything about the other person. It seems more likely that you're retrofitting certainty onto the early part of the relationship from the comfort of your established one.
就像，你怎么可能在两秒钟内就知道呢？你对那个人一无所知。更有可能的是，你在舒适的既定关系中，把这种笃定感回溯到了关系的早期。
So many of the people who responded to my callout just seemed like they were imposing magic on all kinds of utterly ordinary meet-cutes. But then, I talked to Meghan, who seemed a lot like me. When she was in her late 20s, like I am, she was living in New York, like I do, and like me, feeling increasingly concerned she would never meet her life partner, and kept finding herself saying things like this.
回应我号召的很多人似乎都把“魔法”强加于各种完全平凡的邂逅上。但是，我采访了梅根，她看起来很像我。她在20多岁末期，像现在的我一样，住在纽约，像现在的我一样，越来越担心自己永远遇不到人生伴侣，并且不断发现自己说着这样的话：
Well, I'm going to be single forever. Like, this sucks, and I hate it, and you know, I had just kind of resigned myself to, like, whatever, I'll just do my own thing. And I didn't mind being alone.
嗯，我会永远单身。这太烂了，我讨厌这样，你知道，我只是不得不接受了，随它去吧，我会过我自己的日子。我不介意独处。
And then, of course, she met someone. One afternoon, while she was working as a waitress, a couple of guys walked in and sat at the bar. She spotted them immediately.
然后，当然，她遇到了某人。一天下午，当她在做服务员时，几个男人走了进来，坐在吧台。她立刻注意到了他们。
Well, to be honest, I thought his friend was cuter. But the moment that we started talking to each other, there was no doubt. So I wouldn't say it was love at first sight, necessarily, but it was definitely love at first conversation.
好吧，说实话，我觉得他的朋友更可爱。但在我们开始交谈的那一刻，就毫无疑问了。所以我不会说那一定是“一见钟情”，但绝对是“一见如故”。
Like, the minute he opened his mouth, and the minute that we started kind of bantering back and forth, I just knew that I was going to marry him. I just knew it. And I almost started to panic, because you don't know if the other person feels the same way.
就像，在他开口的那一刻，在我们开始互相打趣的那一刻，我就知道我会嫁给他。我就是知道。我甚至开始恐慌，因为你不知道对方是否也有同感。
This guy, Jeff, did feel the same way. By the end of her shift, Meghan was certain Jeff was her person. But she already had plans to go on a date with someone else that night. So she went out, and at the end of the night--
这个叫杰夫的男人，确实有同样的感觉。在她轮班结束时，梅根肯定杰夫就是她的那个人。但她那天晚上已经安排好要和别人约会。于是她还是去了，而在晚上结束时——
I took him back to my house and I slept with him, because I knew that that was the last person that I was going to sleep with before I married Jeff.
我带他回了家，和他发生了关系，因为我知道那是我在嫁给杰夫之前会睡的最后一个人。
What! Really?
什么！真的？
I did. I was like, I'm going to fuck this guy. I know I'm never going to fuck anybody else again, because I'm going to marry that other guy that I just met.
是的。我当时想，我就要和这个家伙睡。我知道我再也不会和别人上床了，因为我要嫁给刚才遇见的那个男人。
You're like, this is my last oat to sow.
你就像是，这是你最后的放纵时刻。
This is my last oat to sow. This is my last one-night stand that I'm ever going to have, and I'm going to go for it.
这是我最后的放纵时刻。这是我这辈子最后一次一夜情，我要去尝试一下。
Meghan got a call from Jeff the next morning while she was still lying in bed with her oat. He asked her out. And a few days later, they went on their first date at a rodeo.
梅根第二天早上在床上还和她的“放纵对象”在一起时，接到了杰夫的电话。他约她出去。几天后，他们第一次约会在竞技场。
And that night, when we were at the rodeo, he leaned over and was like, you know I love you. And I was like, yeah, I know. I know. I love you, too.
那天晚上，当我们在竞技场时，他凑过来，说，你知道我爱你。我说，是的，我知道。我知道。我也爱你。
You're saying it sort of like, matter of fact. Like, obviously, we love each other. Is that what it felt like?
你说的就像是，陈述事实一样。好像，显然我们彼此相爱。那是那种感觉吗？
Yeah, it was like yeah, no shit. Like, duh, you know? I mean, it was truly obvious from the end of the first day that we met.
是的，就像“是啊，废话，肯定啊，你知道吗？”。我的意思是，从我们见面的第一天结束时起，这就非常显而易见。
That is so crazy to me.
这对我来说太疯狂了。
Oh, yeah, 100%.
哦，是的，100%。
Had you ever felt that certainty before?
你之前感受过这种笃定感吗？
Never.
从未。
Never, ever. No, never.
从来没有。不，从来没有。
Meghan sounds so certain, which makes me wonder if perhaps some people are just wired for certainty and I'm not one of them. Hearing these stories feels like window-shopping for love at a store that's closed. I can see all these beautiful things, can imagine what it might be like to wear them, or how life might be different if I owned them, but can't actually try anything on.
梅根听起来是如此笃定，这让我怀疑，也许有些人天生就是为了笃定而生的，而我不是其中之一。听到这些故事感觉就像是在一家已经关门的商店橱窗里买爱情。我能看到所有美好的东西，能想象穿上它们是什么感觉，或者如果我拥有它们生活会有什么不同，但我根本试穿不了任何东西。
Are you and Jeff still together?
你和杰夫还在一起吗？
Jeff and I are not still together. We actually just recently were legally separated. The best way I can describe it is that I met Jeff day drinking in a bar on a Tuesday at, like, 3:00 PM.
杰夫和我已经不在一起了。我们实际上最近刚合法分居。我能描述的最好方式就是，我是在一个周二下午3点在酒吧喝酒时遇到杰夫的。
He's a big drinker, and he has some problems with addiction. And I wasn't able to weather that storm with him after trying for many years-- rehab, and we have kids, and I just couldn't do it anymore. Honestly, that's sort of the heartbreaking thing about it, is that I thought we'd be together forever. We both did.
他是个爱喝酒的人，有一些成瘾问题。我在努力多年后没法在那场风暴中支撑下去——康复中心，我们还有孩子，我实在做不到了。老实说，这才是最令人心碎的部分，因为我以为我们会永远在一起。我们两个都这么认为。
Oh, I'm so sorry.
噢，我非常遗憾。
Yeah.
是的。
Does breaking up with Jeff shake your sense of certainty that you'd had all those years ago?
和杰夫分手会动摇你多年前拥有的那种笃定感吗？
No, not at all.
不，完全不会。
Really?
真的吗？
Not in the least.
一点也不会。
It doesn't make you feel like you were wrong, like you misread something?
这不会让你觉得你是错的，好像你读错了什么？
No. No, not at all.
不。不，完全不会。
I find Meghan convincing. Because even after all that, she's still certain about the connection they had. It was real.
我觉得梅根很有说服力。因为即便在经历了这一切之后，她仍然肯定他们曾拥有的那份连接。那是真实的。
I'd been thinking of certainty as a kind of guarantee. If you had it, everything else would fall into place. But there is no guarantee. I get that certainty doesn't always hit you over the head like a hammer. It can take time. But however you get there, it still seems worth trying to find. Because how lovely to get a break, however brief, from wondering, is this right? I'd like to feel that.
我一直把笃定感当作一种保证。如果你有了它，一切都会顺理成章。但没有什么保证。我明白笃定感并不总是像锤子一样敲击你的头。这需要时间。但无论你如何到达那里，它似乎仍然值得努力寻找。因为从怀疑“这是对的吗？”中获得片刻的休息，哪怕是短暂的，也是多么美好。我想感受到那种感觉。
Aviva DeKornfeld is one of the producers on our show.
阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Three, "He's All That." So I want to introduce you to someone, a kid named Cal. And there's a couple of things Cal really wants you to know about him.
第三幕，“他的一切”。我想向你们介绍一个孩子，名叫卡尔。关于他，有几件事他真的很想让你知道。
I'm 11 years old. I live in New York City. I live with my parents and my cat. I love cats.
我11岁。我住在纽约。我和父母还有猫住在一起。我喜欢猫。
I have a lot of follow up questions. OK, first of all, what is your cat's name?
我有很多后续问题。好吧，首先，你的猫叫什么名字？
Spider. He has a white spot on his chest-- actually, one on his chest, and one near his butt.
“蜘蛛”。它胸口有一个白点——其实，胸口一个，屁股附近一个。
The things I want you to know about Cal-- he's charmingly straightforward, both serious and unserious. And also--
关于卡尔，我想让你们知道的是——他可爱又坦率，既严肃又不严肃。而且——
I also hear that you have your first boyfriend. Is that right?
我还听说你有了第一个男朋友。是这样吗？
Yes.
是的。
First love-- I think if you're looking for a champion of magic, this is the primordial ooze that magic crawls out of. There's no feeling like that first time you like someone and they like you back. It can feel like a little miracle.
初恋——我想如果你在寻找魔法的拥护者，这就是魔法爬出的原始汤。没有什么感觉能比得上你喜欢一个人，而他也喜欢你。这感觉就像一个小奇迹。
Now, Cal's only 11, so having a boyfriend really just means hanging out at school, texting a bunch. They first met at their school's Gender Sexuality Alliance Club.
现在，卡尔才11岁，所以有男朋友基本上意味着在学校一起玩，互相发短信。他们是在学校的性别与性取向联盟俱乐部里认识的。
He was really nice. He helped me settle in, and I really liked him. I began to have feelings for him. Around Thanksgiving, I texted him and told him I liked him. The next day, he texted back and told me he knew it, and that he liked me, too. He then asked if I wanted to be his boyfriend. I said, hell yes.
他真的很好。他帮我安顿下来，我真的很喜欢他。我开始对他产生感情。感恩节前后，我给他发短信说我喜欢他。第二天，他回信说他感觉到了，他也喜欢我。然后他问我愿不愿意做他的男朋友。我说，太愿意了。
What do you like about him?
你喜欢他什么？
He's hilarious. He comes up with the best jokes and the best ideas, and he makes me laugh.
他很幽默。他总能想出最好的笑话和最好的点子，他让我发笑。
I should also mention they're coworkers.
我还要补充一下，他们还是同事。
We're also on the school's paper together.
我们还在学校报社一起工作。
Cal's boyfriend-- he's his editor. I didn't have the heart to tell him that this was maybe not healthy. But it seemed to be working out for them.
卡尔的男朋友——是他的编辑。我没忍心告诉他这可能不太健康。但这似乎对他们来说行得通。
He's my editor, in the Just For Fun column. I make a series of comics about Spider, called "Spider Cat Comics." The first one came out in the first paper two weeks ago, and I think it was pretty good.
他是我的编辑，负责“纯属娱乐”专栏。我创作了一系列关于“蜘蛛”的漫画，叫《蜘蛛猫漫画》。第一篇两周前在第一期报纸上发表了，我觉得还不错。
Given that he's your editor, does that mean that he gives you critiques or notes on the things that you make?
鉴于他是你的编辑，那意味着他会给你创作的作品提建议或意见吗？
He does.
是的。
And what kinds of notes does he give you back on your comics?
他会对你的漫画给出什么样的意见？
He likes them. He says they're pretty creative and cool.
他很喜欢。他说它们很有创意而且很酷。
That's very supportive.
那太支持了。
It is. I'm really glad I have him.
确实。我真的很高兴有他。
I can tell Cal is riding a high. He's close to that pure magic that happens at the start of a relationship. It's that place where you feel like you've got it all figured out. I asked him if he had any advice for other people about how to get there.
我看得出来卡尔正处于兴奋状态。他接近于那种关系开始时发生的纯粹魔法。在那儿，你会觉得自己已经把一切都搞定了。我问他是否对别人有什么建议，关于如何达到那种状态。
Tell them you like them. See what they say. If they don't like you back, it may be hard for you. But at least you took a chance. And with taking a chance, it helps. It really helps. Believe me. I've been through that before. I took the chance, and believe me, not everyone gets it on the first time. Most people don't get it on the first time.
告诉他们你喜欢他们。看看他们怎么说。如果他们不喜欢你，你可能会感到难受。但至少你尝试过。尝试一下，会有帮助的。真的有帮助。相信我。我以前经历过。我试过了，相信我，不是每个人第一次就能成。大多数人第一次都成不了。
But it sounds like you're asking people to be brave.
但听起来你是在要求人们勇敢一点。
Yep.
是啊。
I originally wanted to talk to Cal, because he was experiencing love for the first time. But then, a couple of weeks after we talked, I got word that something had changed. Cal's boyfriend broke up with him.
我最初想采访卡尔是因为他在经历初恋。但随后，在我们交谈几周后，我得到消息说发生了一些变故。卡尔的男朋友和他分手了。
He just said, flat-out, over text, I'm breaking up with you. And I said, what? Why? And he explained he wasn't really feeling it with me, and that it wasn't going to work out. And then, he stopped texting me, and then I yelled at him.
他只是平淡地通过短信说，我和你分手了。我说，什么？为什么？他解释说他对我没感觉了，这段关系不会有结果。然后，他就不再回我短信，我就对他大吼大叫。
Just to clarify, he called him a son of a bitch.
简单说明一下，他骂他是个杂种。
And then, I blocked him.
然后，我把他拉黑了。
Oh, wow. So it was not a good breakup then.
噢，哇。那分手的时候不太愉快。
Yeah, it was not friendly. I wanted to just be friends after that, but it seems he doesn't even want to remember I exist. Before this, I actually pictured a bit of a-- a sort of future with him. But I'm guessing he didn't feel the same.
是的，并不友好。分手后我本来只想做朋友，但看来他连想起我的存在都不愿意。在此之前，我其实构想过一点点——一点点的未来。但我猜他没那种感觉。
Talking to Cal now, he's a changed person. All that boldness, how much he trusted his heart-- he's not as sure now.
现在和卡尔聊天，他变了个人。那种大胆，他对心脏的信任——他现在没那么确定了。
Your heart can lead you to someone who you supposedly like, who's funny and cute, but they're not always the best person for you. I don't know what to do. I don't want to lose-- I don't want to be plunged into darkness and shut down forever. Why does the world have to be like this?
你的心可以引导你走向一个你本以为喜欢的人，觉得他有趣又可爱，但他们并不总是最适合你的人。我不知道该怎么办。我不想输——我不想陷入黑暗，永远封闭自己。为什么世界非要这样呢？
I wish I had the answer, Cal. I don't know why it has to be this way, but I also know it won't be like this forever.
卡尔，我希望我有答案。我不知道为什么非得这样，但我知道这种情况不会永远持续下去。
Cal says, he wants to take a break, not try to find a new boyfriend for a while. And he's going to take a different approach the next time around. He says, before he gets back out there, he wants to do some research. He wants to google articles that will tell him more about how to date, how to meet people. He's got a plan which, to me, sounds like a magic person moving the needle ever so slightly over to math.
卡尔说，他想休息一下，暂时不想找新的男朋友。下一次，他会采取不同的方法。他说，在重新出发之前，他想做一些研究。他想谷歌一些文章，告诉他更多关于如何约会、如何结识人的知识。他制定了一个计划，对我来说，这听起来像是一个“魔法”派的人将指针稍微向“数学”派挪动了一点。
Do you think that if you had to choose one, trusting your head or your heart, which one would you choose, do you think?
你觉得如果必须选一个，相信头脑还是心灵，你会选哪一个？
I would choose head. Head always has the best instincts. Your heart just leads you, as I said, through rose-colored glasses. Your head tells you more practical.
我会选择头脑。头脑总是有最好的直觉。就像我说的，你的心只会引导你，让你戴上玫瑰色的眼镜。你的头脑会告诉你更实际的方案。
Cal's shift in this moment-- it makes sense to me. The times I've been dumped, the last thing I wanted was for someone to tell me to lean into my feelings more. Because, like Cal, I didn't trust my heart. I wanted someone to tell me that there were hard facts to finding love, a process that could be enacted that didn't rely on my dumb feelings.
卡尔此刻的转变——对我来说很有道理。那些被甩的时刻，我最不需要的就是别人告诉我多听从内心的感受。因为像卡尔一样，我不信任我的心。我想要有人告诉我，寻找爱情有硬性事实，有一种可以执行的过程，而不必依赖我那些愚蠢的感情。
That's the thing about the two camps. The allure of each is that they offer a path. And depending on where you are, each one may call to you at a different time. But Cal says he's not all the way gone. He's still making room for his heart whenever it's ready to try again.
这就是这两个阵营的问题所在。每个阵营的诱惑力在于它们提供了一条路径。根据你所处的阶段，它们可能会在不同的时间召唤你。但卡尔说他还没有彻底放弃。他仍在为他的心留出空间，随时准备再次尝试。
As I said, if you didn't have it, you wouldn't find love. Also, it's really weird that heart is represented as love, because it's an organ. Also, the heart shape isn't even what it looks like. It looks more like this blobby, melty, oval thing.
如我所说，如果你没有它，你就不会找到爱情。还有，心脏被代表为爱真的很奇怪，因为它只是个器官。而且，心形甚至根本不是它长得那个样子。它长得更像那种黏糊糊的、融化掉的、椭圆的东西。
I agree, Cal. Sometimes none of this stuff makes any sense at all.
我同意，卡尔。有时这些东西根本就一点意义都没有。
Act Four, "How to Leave a Guy in 10 Days." So far, we've talked a lot about how there can be magic at the beginning of a relationship. But there's another place that magic can pop up, and it's a place you might never think to look for it. Our next story is about someone who's come to believe that you can find magic, know true joy, in a breakup. Here's producer Diane Wu to explain.
第四幕，“十天搞定那个男的”。到目前为止，我们谈论了很多关于关系开始时可能存在的魔法。但魔法还会出现在另一个地方，一个你可能从未想过要去寻找的地方。下一个故事讲述了一个人开始相信，你可以在分手时找到魔法，体会到真正的快乐。制作人戴安·吴来解释一下。
I was once in a 10-year relationship where the question of is this what I really want started to creep in around year four. And so for six years, this was the big unmagical and uncalculatable question of my life. When do you stay, and when do you go?
我曾经有过一段长达10年的感情，四年左右时，“这是我真正想要的吗？”的问题开始潜入我的心头。所以在那六年里，这是我生活中最大的、无法定义、无法计算的问题。什么时候该留下，什么时候该走？
Eventually, I ended it. And since then, I've been extra wary of being in the wrong relationship again. And maybe as a way to stay sharp, alert, I like hearing about how other people deal with this kind of decision. The writer Marie Phillips has a very specific approach to this question. Think about it like you're at the movies.
最终，我结束了它。从那以后，我格外小心，避免再次陷入错误的关系。也许是为了保持敏锐、警觉，我喜欢听别人如何处理这种决定。作家玛丽·菲利普斯对待这个问题有一种非常具体的方法。想象一下就像你在电影院一样。
I have never regretted walking out of a movie. I have, many times, regretted not walking out of a movie. Not finishing things is one of the great joys of life.
我从不后悔中途离场。我有很多次后悔没有中途离场。不把事情坚持到底，是人生最大的乐趣之一。
I've never walked out of a film, so I don't know the feeling.
我从没从电影院中途退场过，所以我不知道那是什么感觉。
You've never walked out of a film?
你从未从中途退场？
No, I feel like I signed up for this, and--
不，我觉得我签了字，而且——
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
--maybe something good will happen, still.
——也许依然会有好事发生。
Have you ever got to the end of the film and thought, I wish I hadn't wasted 2 and 1/2 hours of my life on that?
你有没有过看完电影心想，真不该浪费两小时三十分钟生命的时刻？
Yes, for sure.
当然有。
On the whole--
总的来说——
But it literally has never occurred to me that I could have left.
但我真的从来没想到过我可以离开。
If the first half-hour is terrible, it's so unlikely to get good. And that is the point at which you can just get up and go.
如果前三十分钟很糟糕，它好起来的可能性太小了。而那正是你可以直接起身走人的时候。
And you never wonder more about what happened or how they brought it home or any of that?
你从来没有好奇过后面发生了什么，或者他们是怎么结尾的之类的吗？
No, no.
没有，完全没有。
Marie became this cheerful leaver of relationships fairly recently. She discovered the joy of walking out of things, actually, on a first date. He was a film director and asked her to see a movie, a 3D movie, by Jean-Luc Godard.
玛丽在相当近的时候变成了一个愉快的离开者。实际上，她在第一次约会时就发现了离场的快乐。对方是位电影导演，约她看电影，一部让-吕克·戈达尔的3D电影。
It wasn't just normal 3D, like when you see on a Marvel movie. He was doing things like, your left eye would be still watching one image, and then he would turn the image on your right eye, so your right eye would suddenly be seeing something completely different.
那不仅仅是普通的3D，就像你在漫威电影里看到的那样。他在做一些动作，比如你的左眼仍在看一个图像，然后他会转动右眼的图像，所以你的右眼会突然看到完全不同的东西。
Whoa. I feel like my stomach is turning just thinking about it.
哇。我光是想想就觉得胃里一阵翻江倒海。
Yeah, so it's nausea-inducing just to hear the idea, but can you imagine-- so I'm sitting in there, and I'm like, I feel sick within minutes. Really fast I thought, I feel sick, and I don't want to be in here. So I just said to him, I'm going to leave now.
是啊，所以听着就让人想吐。你能想象吗？所以我坐在那儿，几分钟内就觉得不舒服。非常快，我想，我感觉恶心，我不想待在这里。所以我直接对他说，我现在要走了。
It was exciting. Marie felt cool and powerful. He stayed. She went and got a glass of wine at the bar. It ended up being a great date. After the film, on the ferry home, they had their first kiss. Two weeks later, the director told her that he loved her. It was the first time any boyfriend had ever told her that. Six months later, they were living together.
那很令人兴奋。玛丽感觉很酷，很有力量。他留下了。她去酒吧喝了一杯酒。那最终成了一次伟大的约会。电影结束后，在回家的渡轮上，他们有了第一次亲吻。两周后，导演告诉她他爱她。这是第一次有男朋友对她这么说。六个月后，他们同居了。
We had a great time. He's extremely funny. He's very charming. He was a really delightful person. He was just a joy to be around. When he would come home, I'd feel like a puppy that had been left. You know, I'd be bouncing with excitement to see him. He got on well with my family. My friends liked him. We got on really, really well.
我们度过了美好的时光。他非常风趣。他很迷人。他确实是个令人愉快的人。和他相处真是一种乐趣。当他回家时，我觉得自己像只被遗弃的小狗。你知道，我蹦蹦跳跳地期待见到他。他和我的家人相处得很好。我的朋友也喜欢他。我们相处得非常、非常融洽。
And leaving movies midway-- it became their thing, together. They would do it all the time. I'm telling you all of this because a few years in, things got rough, and Marie had to decide whether or not to walk out of the relationship.
中途离场看电影——成了他们的事。他们经常那样做。我告诉你们这一切是因为几年后，日子变得艰难了，玛丽不得不决定是否离开这段关系。
What happened was, the director said he wanted to have an open relationship. Marie was game to try it out. She loved him. She thought maybe she'd change and it would start to feel OK, or maybe he'd change. But nobody changed. She lived for a year in indecision, going back and forth, trying to make it work.
发生的事情是，导演说他想要一段开放关系。玛丽愿意尝试。她爱他。她想也许她会改变，感觉就会变好，或者也许他会改变。但没人改变。她在优柔寡断中生活了一年，反反复复，试图让它奏效。
I've been there. I don't recommend it. My indecision looked like finding myself reading the same advice column over and over, recognizing the advice was for me but never following it. I could never tell if it was me or the situation that needed to change.
我也经历过。我不推荐。我的优柔寡断表现为我发现自己一遍又一遍地阅读同样的建议专栏，认识到建议是给我的，却从不照做。我永远无法判断是自己还是情况需要改变。
In Marie's case, all that back-and-forth ended in one moment when it all became clear to her. She realized she didn't like the movie anymore, and that it wasn't going to pick up in the second half. It was during a conversation in their apartment.
在玛丽的案例中，所有那些反反复复在某一刻结束了，一切都变得清晰起来。她意识到她不再喜欢这部“电影”了，而且下半场也不会有好转。那是在他们公寓里的一次谈话中。
And I remember, at the time, feeling this extremely physical need to be as far away from him as I could possibly get. In that moment, I felt the opposite of love. Because in a way, love, for me, is the feeling that I want to be close. And then, the opposite feeling of that is like, I just-- I need to get out of here. I need to be as far away from this person as I could possibly get.
我记得，当时感觉到一种极度身体上的需要，离他越远越好。在那一刻，我感觉到了爱的对立面。因为在某种程度上，爱，对我来说，就是我想靠近的感觉。而相反的感觉就是，我只是——我需要离开这里。我需要离这个人越远越好。
Marie walked out of their apartment and kept walking in one direction until she couldn't go any farther. A few days later, she officially ended the relationship.
玛丽走出了他们的公寓，朝着一个方向一直走，直到走不动为止。几天后，她正式结束了这段关系。
I mean, that sounds like a terrible experience, but also it's like-- but it's also so rare that moments are so clarifying, that you're, like-- you don't even have to think. It's not even a decision, right? You just go. You have to go. There isn't an alternative, whereas I think most of life is somewhere in the mushy middle.
我的意思是，那听起来是一次可怕的经历，但也很少有这种时刻如此清晰，以至于你甚至不需要思考。这不是一个决定，对吧？你只是走了。你必须走。没有替代方案，而我觉得大多数生活都在那种“模糊的中间地带”。
I mean, yeah, it's true. It's very rare that you're going to be 100% miserable. But when you're 60% miserable, that's still too miserable. That's more than half. It's not like I have a spreadsheet on this, by the way. But that feeling where most of the time you're feeling terrible-- that's not a way to live.
是的，是真的。你很少会百分之百地痛苦。但当你百分之六十痛苦时，那也太痛苦了。超过了一半。顺便说一下，我并没有为这个做表格。但那种大部分时间你都感觉糟糕的感觉——那不是一种生活方式。
You know what is a way to live? Think about it like you're at the movies.
你知道什么是生活方式吗？像在电影院看电影一样去思考。
You know how when you go to see a film, and you walk in and it's daylight, and then you come out and it's dark?
你知道当你去看电影时，走进去是白天，出来却是黑夜吗？
Yeah, I hate that.
是的，我讨厌那样。
When I picture walking out of a film, when I visualize walking out of a film in my mind, I am always walking out into the sunlight.
当我构想从中途退场时，当我在脑海里想象中途离场时，我总是走进阳光里。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
[LAUGHS] I'm never walking out into the dark, in the rain. I'm always just stepping out into the sunshine. When I see unhappy couples, I'm just like, oh my god, you're both keeping someone else from the joy of being-- someone who could love you is on their own right now.
（笑声）我从不走进黑暗和雨里。我总是步入阳光中。当我看到不幸的夫妇时，我会想，天哪，你们都在阻止对方享受快乐——那个能爱你的人现在正孤身一人。
Right.
对。
If you broke up, someone that loves you could be with you, and someone who loves your husband or your wife could be with them. And just think how much happier all of you would be. And instead, there's some poor single person on Hinge, desperately looking through the profiles, who'd be perfect for you. And you're not on Hinge, because you're too busy fighting with your wife.
如果你分手了，那个爱你的人就能和你在一起，那个爱你丈夫或妻子的人就能和他们在一起。想想你们所有人会快乐多少。而相反，Hinge上有个可怜的单身汉，绝望地翻看着资料，而那个人本是你的绝配。你却不在Hinge上，因为你太忙于和妻子争吵了。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Yeah. I mean, god, I'm just-- I'm like, everybody break up!
是的。我是说，天哪，我觉得大家都分手吧！
Happy Valentine's Day, America.
祝美国情人节快乐。
Diane Wu is one of the producers on our show. Before we end our show, I think it's only fair that I answer which camp I believe in-- math or magic. In truth, after dating around for most of my 20s, I got tired of both. Magic steered me wrong, and going out on dates just to go on dates also felt exhausting.
戴安·吴是我们节目的制作人之一。在结束节目之前，我觉得公平起见，我也应该回答一下我信奉哪个阵营——数学还是魔法。说实话，在20多岁大部分时间里都在约会之后，我对两者都厌倦了。魔法让我误入歧途，而为了约会而约会也让人精疲力竭。
So I made up my own theory about what to do. It was kind of mathy. Actually, it was a little like what Zarna did, though nowhere near as specific. I made myself a list of 10 qualities I wanted in a partner, and it was pretty simple. It said things like, I want him to be kind. I want him to appreciate the arts. I was a cellist at the time. I want him to be the kind of person I'd want to call when something funny happens.
所以我编造了自己的理论。这有点“数学味”。事实上，这和扎尔娜的做法有点像，虽然没那么具体。我为自己列了一份我想在伴侣身上拥有的10个品质清单，非常简单。上面写着，我想要他善良，我想要他欣赏艺术。（我当时是大提琴手）。我想要他成为那种发生有趣的事情时，我第一个想打电话的人。
And I made a rule for myself that if I was dating a guy that I liked, if I started to get freaked out about whether or not it felt magical enough, I had to pull out the list. And if it was true that he had a majority of the things that I put on my list, I would keep giving it a shot.
我还为自己定了一条规矩：如果我正在和一个喜欢的男士约会，如果我开始惊慌失措于它是否足够有“魔法感”，我就必须拿出清单。如果他确实具备了清单上大部分品质，我就继续努力。
Eventually, I met a public school teacher who did art on the side. We laughed over pizza, talked about The Great British Baking Show, which had just debuted in the States. We went on another date, and then another. And any time I left a date and thought, wow, that was fun and easy but was it fun and easy enough, I'd return to the list.
最终，我遇到了一位公立学校的老师，业余时间搞艺术。我们一起吃着披萨大笑，谈论着刚在美国上映的《英国家庭烘焙大赛》。我们又约会了一次，又一次。每当我结束约会心想，哇，这很轻松愉快，但够轻松愉快吗？我就会回去看那个清单。
Ah, yes. I still have found someone with a majority of the qualities I want, that really likes me, too. I stopped referring to the list after a while. And then one day, sitting on the couch, something happened. Remember that app that went around a couple of years ago that took a picture of your face and showed you what you look like much older, added wrinkles, and gray hair? One day, my partner did it.
啊，是的。我还是找到了一个拥有我大部分想要的品质、同时也真心喜欢我的人。过了一段时间后，我就不再看那个清单了。然后有一天，坐在沙发上，发生了一些事。还记得几年前流行过的一个应用程序吗？它会给你的脸拍张照，展示你老了之后的样子，加上皱纹和灰白的头发。有一天，我的伴侣试了一下。
On screen appeared an image of him in his 80s-- with jowls and exaggerated laugh lines, wispy eyebrows. And a feeling crept up that I didn't expect. It surprised me. The instant I saw his face there, I thought, I'd like to be around to see that.
屏幕上出现了他80多岁的形象——长着赘肉，夸张的笑纹，稀疏的眉毛。一种我不曾预料到的感觉涌了上来。它让我惊讶。就在我看到他那张脸的瞬间，我想，我愿意活到那时候去见证它。
I have no illusions about having cracked some code. But I do think if you find someone and it lasts in a way that makes you happy, no matter how you get there, it's its own kind of magic.
我不奢望自己破解了什么密码。但我确实认为，如果你找到某人，而这段关系以一种让你快乐的方式持续下去，无论你是怎么走到这一步的，这本身就是一种魔法。
Today's show was produced by Aviva DeKornfeld. People who put together today's show include Elna Baker, Chris Benderev, Phia Bennin, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Valerie Kipnis, Seth Lind, Katherine Rae Mondo, Alaa Mostafa, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Lilly Sullivan, Nancy Updike, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker.
今天的节目由阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德制作。参与今天节目的人包括埃尔纳·贝克、克里斯·本德雷夫、菲亚·本宁、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、伊曼纽尔·佐齐、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯、塞斯·林德、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、阿拉·穆斯塔法、斯托·尼尔森、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、弗朗西丝·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、莉莉·沙利文、南希·厄普代克、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks to Ovi Aragon, Burt Harvey, and the Utah County Passport and Marriage License Office, Alex Fulton, Dave Rizzo, Kim Adams, Marcie Schneider, Sarah Davis, Sabrina Hyman, Sarah King, Emily Ogle, Sara Collins, Francesca Street, Cheryl Hiltzik, Jacob Ritter, and Lori Gottlieb.
我们的编辑经理是莎拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼。资深编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。特别感谢奥维·阿拉贡、伯特·哈维，以及犹他县护照和结婚证办公室、亚历克斯·富尔顿、戴夫·里佐、金·亚当斯、玛西·施奈德、莎拉·戴维斯、萨布丽娜·海曼、莎拉·金、艾米丽·奥格尔、莎拉·柯林斯、弗朗西斯卡·斯特里特、谢丽尔·希尔齐克、雅各布·里特和洛里·戈特利布。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free-- also, there's all kinds of other stuff-- lists of favorite shows, videos, tons of other things there. Again-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费在线收听我们超过750集的存档——还有各种其他内容——最喜欢的节目列表、视频、以及海量其他东西。再次重申——thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交易所发送给公共广播电台。
Thanks to my boss, Ira Glass. Why is he out this week? Well, the other day when he and Torey Malatia were working their side job, they were like, wait, do you cut the red wire or the white wire?
感谢我的老板伊拉·格拉斯。他这周为什么不在？嗯，那天他和托雷·马拉蒂亚在做副业时，他们说，等等，你是剪红线还是白线？
Like, both of us simultaneously just looked at each other, and boom.
“我们就像同时看着对方，轰。”
I'm Tobin Low. Join us next week with more stories from This American Life.
我是托宾·洛。下周请继续收听《美国生活》的更多故事。